il ya un dossier qui est sorti ce
week-end qui a fait beaucoup de bruit il
ya une enquête du monde et c'est une
petite d'art cas puisque un haut
conseiller de l'elysée a confié une fois
de plus au monde que le gouvernement au
monde le journal que le gouvernement
avait peur de plusieurs hardy nature
pour 2022
voilà au sommet de l'état d'hypothèse de
l'émergence d'une figure populiste hors
parti est un véritable objet
d'inquiétude dans la perspective de 2022
alors que la défiance contre le pouvoir
s'est encore épaissi dans la crise
sanitaire
un zemmour un rat ou un hanouna pourquoi
pas une elise lucet qui incarnent chacun
à leur manière cette rupture entre le
peuple et les élites peuvent faire
irruption dans le jeu et tenter de
poursuivre la vague de dégagements de
2017 va ainsi croire un poids lourd du
gouvernement
et selon le monde emmanuel bach ont fait
le choix de traiter ces personnalités
plutôt que de les ignorer
selon le président cette stratégie
contribuera à affaiblir le pouvoir
d'attraction et sait-on si système alors
moi on là dessus ça c'est ça toujours et
voilà ça fait longtemps qu'on parle de
ça mais ça nous fait marrer cv
révélations du monde n'ont pas du tout
plu à gilbert collard a laissé gilbert
collard allawi c'est dans le
rassemblement national il est il était
vénère contre moi sur une fille
j'aimerais demander une basse et vénère
pas bien le garder sinon sur ce
phénomène des professeurs à holt oui
mais raout n'y est pour rien enfin quand
même c'est pas une question d'éthique
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas sa faute si
dans un monde en manque de
représentation
les braves gens sont fiers d'eux de se
rattacher à raul qui lui ligne et il n'y
est pour rien enfin moi je préfère je
préfère quand on choisit ce raout comme
béraud plutôt que nous n'avons
maintenant j'ai peut-être tort un
professeur il a pensé à lui pense tout
le temps moi oui vous offrez le public
public moi je vous trouvez pas qu'il
ressemble au chat garfield
c'est vrai même grille alors à jouer je
lui ai répondu
donc j'ai mis sur twitter j'ai mis 6 y
va faire un brushing ça va te détendre
parce que tu parle de moi dans une story
rien à voir va faire un lissage
brésilien ça te fera du bien et il m'a
rendez pour de bon sachez le voyage de
quelques instants avant l'émission
regardez cherchent ils à l'honneur
puisque ta seule préoccupation et le
brushing donne mon adresse
[Rires]
elle sera ravie de me coincer je pense
qu'il n'est pas là voilà mais cette fois
il a pensé avoir à chaque fois ils
pensent à moi mais je peux toujours
merci donc à moi à chaque fois voilà
mais bon c'est au coeur des
préoccupations mais là il a promis donc
ça prouve que vous êtes une figure
auquel les politiques page
pour revenir à ce que ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure sur raul sur zemmour sur
vous sur jean marie bigard beaucoup
disent qu une des raisons pour
lesquelles le président les a appelé les
uns et les autres
zemmour côté-là été apostrophé dans la
rue raout quand il est allé le voir
bigard récemment c'est une c'est parce
que c'est une façon aussi de ne plus les
mettre hors système depuis les faire à
des gens antisystème et des gens qui
parlent avec le système est donc moins
de pouvoir d'attraction et donc du coup
le fait que les gens pourraient se
pouvait s'identifier à eux ça diminue
mais il voulait réagir maintenant je
voulais juste dire qu'avec raymond à
17h06 allez-vous vous les avez en réel
ça crée un peu mais bon on fait avec
ouais c'est un battant mais bon je suis
bercot la voilà il s'est fait plaisir
elle avait envie de dire le nom d'anna y
croient que c'est une technique ça te
dit que je crois que c'est laid défensif
la m prix aussi c'est pourquoi vous êtes
une figure populaire c'est normal mais
si ça l'avait rejoint moi ça m'a fait
marrer un bon endroit fait plus marié
voilà sur les noms kimuaki et jeux j'y
crois sur les noms qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure il y avait à naha raul moi je
crois beaucoup aux opposé zemmour et
hanouna je pense que zemmour est capable
de rassembler beaucoup de gens pour les
élections est capable de faire peur aux
politiques comme je pense que toi de
l'autre côté tu es capable aussi de
faire peur aux politiques
si tu demanderas des gens de voter pour
untel ou pour untel parce que c'est
parfois c'est à quelques voix sait
quelles que soient ses quelques milliers
de voix que ça joue et je pense que
anneaux hanouna d'un côté zemmour de
l'autre moi je suis persuadé que si vous
avez envie de lancer un parti ou de
dette derrière un gars de dire voter
pour lui il ya beaucoup de gens qui
écoutent et c'est pour ça que tout est
le gouvernement ils virent heures un
robinet alors ok nous dire moi je fais
jamais demandé
jamais l'idée a demandé voilà de voter
pour quelqu'un qui que ce soit parce que
moi je vais vous dire un truc moi je
pense qu'on peut pas être à la place des
gens que tu vois je te le dis - les mots
je pense que tu seras d'accord avec moi
moi je vous dirais année mais on vit pas
leur vie il ya des mecs qui vit des
journées difficiles tous les jours et un
moment où je vais vous dire je le dis à
chaque fois et il ya plein de gens mine
de rien qui tombe sur le dos des
électeurs du rassemblement national 1
moi je vais vous dire la vérité moi bien
sûr je voterai jamais pour le
rassemblement national
mais c'est pas pour ça que je vais
tomber sur les électeurs du
rassemblement national le mec tu sais
pas ce qui vit tous les jours
peut-être que le mec il a voté à droite
il a voté à gauche il a voté au milieu
et bas il a toujours une ville mais il
s'en sort pas il vit un moment ne sais
pas parce qu'il peut être pas cela parce
qu'il est raciste ou pocket il ya aussi
plein de gens parce qu'ils disent et
laurie lapeyre un moment essayé bien
peut-être moi je le ferai jamais mais
c'est vrai que ça peut être dangereux
parce que quand on entend leurs idées
sur l'immigration de ça on est
complètement opposés à ce qu'ils pensent
mais en tout cas voilà je vous dis
tomber sur les électeurs nous ont
assurés du raz du rassemblement national
moi ça je supporte pas les mecs qu'il
est qui leur tombent dessus parce qu'ils
savent qu'ils connaissent pas leur vie
mine de rien voilà il ya des gens qui
souffrent il ya des gens qui disent vas
nous ça fait 30 ans qu'on souffre qu'on
a voté à droite et ben on sap avancés on
a voté à gauche ça n'a pas dansé on a
voté au milieu on est toujours dans la
même merde un moment qu'est ce qu'on
fait et donc voilà donc on peut pas se
mettre à la place des gens donc moi je
pense vraiment que c'est pas notre place
à nous le dire se voter pour untel ou
untel nous on est très content on vient
sur un plateau il fait chaud on rigole
on est bien on va faire les boîtes à
paris on va essayer de faire gagner deux
cent cinquante mille euros non mais
c'est vrai mais sans lien mais y'a des
mecs et bien je peux dire tous les jours
ils sont derrière c'est en lien avec ce
que ce que je disais hier je me suis
énervé c'est en lien quand je parlais
d'huile sur le feu
vous parlez de vie que c'est pas les
vôtres vous êtes ça dans la merde moi si
ça rend mon souci d'aujourd'hui c'est
d'aller trouver un film pour la piscine
gonflable c'est pas ma vie moi les sites
et donc c'est quand j'en parle je prends
le risque d'en parler de me faire
défoncer derrière mais c'est pas pour
moi que j'en pars c'est pour les gens
qui habitent là dedans c'est pour les
gens qui vivent cité c'est ce que tu dis
faut pas parler à la place des gens
parce qu'après tu arrives premier parti
de france
rassemblement national c'est le premier
parti de france il faut il faut
respecter ce parti là moi je voterai
jamais pour eux ça c'est clair net et
précis
sauf que les gens me disent on a tout
essayé droite-gauche milieu comme tu as
dit à un moment donné ils entendent des
trucs on leur met des trucs dans la tête
les gens viennent sur les plateaux télé
surtout les voleurs mais vrai truc dans
la tête surtout il ya des gens qui
disent nous on est on est je vous dire
on est à bout on est on n'arrive pas
notre moi le dit
le 10 du mois on est dans la merde on
sait le faire on va le finir assurée par
moments on pourra pas être plus dans la
merde que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
ce que disent certains de certaines
personnes bernard qu on peut comprendre
ça tout à fait on peut en vip à la même
façon moi je vois est tout à leur
valérie a eu raison de préciser que
justement on a vu une espèce de
solidarité qui s'est passé durant ce
confinement
ça c'est très touchant et très
bouleversant je trouve non vie plutôt
seule femme moi je vis plutôt seul donc
forcément mais c'est normal vous fait
pipi au lit ce qui n'aurait jamais dû
dire ça oui j'en attends c'est pas qu'un
mode de rejet s'est pas seulement les
gens qui votent pour la sont la semaine
s'est pas seulement des gens qui disent
j'ai essayé à droite ça par an chez ces
ego chez porcher soit aussi parce qu'on
rassemble un saut mal prône des idées
qui leur correspond prendre son actif
nascar aux essais paca vote de rejet
oui mais en a beaucoup et ça montre que
le front national quand tu vois front
national à 30% leur assemblée nationale
30% tu sais qu'à la moitié
c'est un vol de roger je suis désolé et
la moitié il reste beaucoup à faire
baisser la prime est quand même oui mais
quand tu es à 15% normalement et tout le
monde l'a 35 à 15 elles sont de vote de
rejet et je te le dis et je pense qu'il
ya des gens qui sont à bout donc moi en
tout cas voilà je voterai jamais pour
information mais je suis pas là moi je
suis pas un donneur de leçons de dire
'voilà bats toi tu votes pour
l'assemblement nationales et 21 teintes
1 1 voilà je vais vous aider voilà
chacun voit la vie sa vie chacun voit
midi à sa porte qu'on y met je peux vous
dire on peut pas se mettre à la place
des autres
ça reste secret et les personnels et ses
propres à chacun
chacun fait ce qu'il veut question pour
geoffrey tosi mois le front national
c'est pareil je voterai jamais pour eux
c'est une évidence tu comprends les
jours voilà parce qu'ils étaient riquet
et voilà moi je suis tu comprends qu'un
animateur ou un ou un mec voile a connu
dix on veut on vote pour telle ou telle
personne ou ça te dérange non moi ça me
dérange pas par contre ce qui par contre
ce qui m'énerve j'entendais raymond en
parlait il ya deux minutes moi j'adore
vraiment parce que c'est un mec qu'on a
l'impression qu'on allait chercher
dehors
et moi je moi je me retrouve en en
raymond est moulé peut-être et le fait
qu'il ait des éditeurs sont même kelly
qu'elle en est je trouve ça nul parce
que dans le monde dans lequel on vit
aujourd'hui en fait faut faire partie
d'un milieu pour parler de ce milieu là
et j'en compte que c'est dommage parce
qu'aujourd'hui tu peux plus rien dire
mais ça je suis pour la liberté
d'expression donner son avis on peut le
dire et s'insultaient on peut discuter
comme on fait du btp ne pas être
d'accord